ti l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
au gouvernement sur des sujets européens
mais auparavant nous allons regrouper
deux questions qu'il pose sur un autre
qui porte sur un autre sujet la parole
est à monsieur jacques myard
merci monsieur le président et je vais
la prendre depuis ce matin le manège
médiatique s'emballe à nouveau à la
suite des révélations de wikileaks selon
lesquelles nos chers amis américains
écoutent les présidents de la république
des ministres et même des députés ce qui
prouve
est ce qui prouve qu aux yeux de la
aînés salle que les députés valent bien
un président de la république
mais s'agit-il vraiment de révélations
puisque nous sommes entre nous et que
personne ne nous écoute
il y a là des révélations que pour les
naïfs
car de gaulle nous a appris depuis
longtemps que les états n'ont pas d'amis
nous ne vivons pas dans un monde de
bisounours nos alliés sont d'abord des
concurrents économiques et diplomatiques
ils ne font aucun cadeau y compris nos
chers partenaires européens
alors nos ministres n'ont pas à se
répandre sur les téléphones portables et
raconter leur vie je m'aime je vais même
vous dire plus si après les nécessaire
représentation diplomatique monsieur le
premier ministre que vous ferez pour
rappeler fermement à washington qu'il
s'agit là d' écoute inadmissible si nos
chers allié américain jure la main sur
le coeur qu'ils ne recommenceront plus
ne les croyez pas conformément à l'adage
de virgile jamais de confiance dans
l'alliance avec un puissant mais c'est à
nous et à nous seuls de défendre nos
intérêts et de nous en donner les moyens
de sortir de notre angélisme de regarder
le monde tel qu'il est et non comme le
rêvent les euros et atlantique au bea
monsieur le premier ministre allez vous
enfin posé à plat les relations franco
américaines
certes en matière d' écoute mais aussi
en matière d'applications
extraterritoriale de leurs lois monsieur
le premier ministre
quelles mesures concrètes allez vous
prendre pour répondre à l'amour pressent
que nous porte nous chers allié
américain
merci monsieur myard la parole est au
président bruno le roux monsieur le
premier ministre
l'amitié entre les peuples a des
exigences qu'ils échappent pas
aux règles élémentaires du respect
mutuel les etats-unis ont dérogé à ses
règles élémentaires en procédant à la
mise sous écoute de trois présidents de
la république successifs jacques chirac
nicolas sarkozy françois hollande sous
écoutes de la nsa jacques chirac nicolas
sarkozy et françois hollande est est il
l'ennemi des états unis la france
représente tel un danger pour les états
unis une menace en aucune manière et à
aucun titre
le fait est qu un système d coûte de
gland de grande ampleur quasi addictif
s'est emparé de la msa après le 11
septembre 2001 ne distingue en plus amis
et ennemis écoute de sécurité et écoute
généralisée collecte de renseignement
aient envie de tout savoir
chers collègues de la révélation ces
faits inacceptables a provoqué une
réaction normale et immédiate de la
france et dès ce matin le président de
la république en est informé les
responsables parlementaires à l'elysée
sur tous les bancs de cette assemblée
nous condamnons cette pratique
détestable dont la gravité ne doit pas
être sous-estimée elle est une atteinte
évidente à la souveraineté de la france
un moment où nous affrontons des défis
considérables dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme où nous devons nous mêmes
renforcer nos moyens et nos règles et
c'est ce que nous allons faire cet
après-midi par la loi les révélations de
wikileaks abîme la confiance et l'esprit
de coopération qui lient la france et
les états unis
monsieur le premier ministre lorsque
l'on à un ami on l'appelle on ne
l'écoutent pas de toute évidence les
agissements découvert ne peuvent rester
sans conséquences
pouvez-vous indiquer à la représentation
nationale la façon dont nous entendons
assurer notre sécurité et répondre à
cette grave atteinte qui a été fait à
notre souveraineté
merci la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre manuel valls
le président monsieur le député milliard
monsieur le président le roux mesdames
et messieurs les députés en vous
répondant à chacun j'imagine que je
répond aussi aux autres groupes et la
plupart d'entre vous depuis ce matin
chacun se pose des questions légitimes
or depuis 2013 soit déjà deux ans la
presse a eu l'occasion de distiller et
publié une partie des dossiers
qu'edouard snowden a capté au sein de là
est né ça parmi eux figurent à plusieurs
reprises la confirmation de l'espionnage
systématique et sur longue durée de
dirigeants et de hauts fonctionnaires
d'état étrangers ces pratiques cible des
pays proches alliés des etats unis
il est public que le brésil et
l'allemagne au moins ont été concernés
aujourd'hui les documents publiés par
deux journaux français en collaboration
avec wikileaks concernent la france
il pointe le fait que des pratiques
similaires ont été conduites à
l'encontre de personnalités politiques
et administratives françaises pendant
longue de longues années et jusqu'au
plus haut niveau
trois présidents de la république
présent république a immédiatement réagi
en convoquant le conseil de défense il a
réuni à midi les présidents de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat les
présidents des commissions concernées
celui de la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement ainsi que l'ensemble des
présidents des groupes politiques des
deux assemblées
cette réunion a été l'occasion au delà
des nuances et des avis qui peuvent
diverger mais de mesures et de partager
l'émotion et la colère qui dans un
mouvement d'unité et rennes l'ensemble
de la représentation nationale et le
pouvoir exécutif
face à ces pratiques inacceptables
oui inacceptable émanant d'un pays ami
ces informations sont très graves ces
pratiques sont anormales entre états
démocratiques
alliée de longue date d'autant plus que
le deux pays portent un message
universel de défense et de promotion de
l'état de droit
non il n'est pas légitime au nom des
intérêts nationaux de procéder à la
surveillance des communications de
dirigeants politiques
de ses proches alliés et de leurs
collaborateurs que ses dirigeants
d'ailleurs appartiennent à la majorité
ou à l'opposition le président la
république le rappelait ce matin
non contrairement à certaines
spéculations médiatiques
la france ne pratique pas la
surveillance et le ciblage des
communications des dirigeants politiques
de ses partenaires européens ou de ses
alliés
aucun dirigeant politique responsable
monsieur mien ne peut s'autoriser la
naïveté dans le monde contemporain
contemporain même entre démocratie amis
et proches les intérêts nationaux
restent les intérêts nationaux
mais lorsqu'on partage des valeurs
communes
le respect réciproque de la souveraineté
est un principe fondamental pour établir
maintenir et faire prospérer des
relations de confiance pour la sécurité
de nos peuples respectifs ces pratiques
constituent donc une très grave
violation de l'esprit de confiance qui
doit nous animer les etats unis doivent
reconnaître non seulement le danger que
de tels agissements font peser pour nos
libertés mais aussi tout faire et vite
pour réparer les dégâts que cela
occasionne dans les relations entre pays
alliés et entre les états unis
d'amérique et la france si de fait les
révélations aujourd'hui ne constitue une
véritable surprise pour personne
ce qui ne veut pas dire monsieur myard
qu'il faut succombé dans le cynisme sur
ces questions là cela n'atténue en rien
l'émotion et la colère
elles sont légitimes la france ne
tolérera aucun agissement mettant en
cause sa sécurité et ses intérêts
fondamentaux
le sujet avait déjà été évoqué entre
l'été 2013 et le voyage d'état du
président de la république aux états
unis début 2014
des explications claires et franches
avait été demandée par les autorités
françaises des engagements avaient
d'ailleurs été pris par nos alliés
américains
ils doivent être fermement rappelé est
strictement respectée
il faut sans nul doute aller plus loin
encore dans ses engagements
il est souhaitable qu entre alliés un
code de bonne conduite soit établie en
matière de renseignement et de respect
de la souveraineté politique dans ce
cadre le ministre des affaires
étrangères laurent fabius à convoquer
sans délai l'ambassadrice des états unis
pour demander des explications
officielles et faire directement part de
la position des autorités françaises le
président de la république cela a déjà
été dit s'entretiendra dans les
prochaines heures avec le président
barack obama afin de s'assurer que les
états unis réitèrent des engagements
clairs et précis à sa demande
le coordonnateur du renseignement
monsieur didier le bret est le directeur
général de la sécurité extérieure
bernard bajolet se rendront très vite
aux états unis pour vérifier le
renouvellement et l'approfondissement de
nos accords de coopération dans le
domaine du renseignement
la confiance en ce domaine la france
s'honore de la construire chaque jour
elle conduit une coopération fructueuse
avec les états unis contre le terrorisme
contre la prolifération des armes de
destruction massive contre les filières
du crime organisé international
cette coopération nous l'assumons
pleinement la faisait messieurs les
députés le principal enseignement que
l'on doit tirer de cette affaire c'est
que notre pays doit veiller en
permanence à perfectionner les moyens
dont il s'est doté pour protéger
l'indépendance nationale en sécurisant
le domaine des communications
stratégiques et cela bien au delà des
domaines diplomatique ou militaire il
faut également et vous le savez être
capable de le faire dans le domaine du
renseignement ou encore de la sécurité
des télécommunications et de
l'informatique
ces préoccupations sont au coeur de la
politique du gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les députés la
réponse de la france à ces révélations
est un message de clarté et de fermeté
face à ce qui n'est pas acceptable
notre pays est un allié loyal qui sait
ce qu'il doit aux états unis au peuple
américain dans son histoire mais la
gratitude ne l'empêchera jamais d'être
indépendant la loyauté n'est pas
l'alignement
la mission assignée par le président de
la république au gouvernement de veiller
en toutes circonstances à protéger la
liberté de nos concitoyens en france
comme à l'étranger
et contrairement au choix pratiqué dans
d'autres pays nous avons fait un choix
clair concernant le projet de loi sur le
renseignement qui vous sera soumis pour
le vote final
cet après midi et qui est totalement
fidèle à la proche que nous portons il
encadre étroitement l'ensemble des
méthodes de surveillance
il crée un outil de contrôle puissant
composé de 9 personnes indépendantes
dont quatre magistrats issus des deux
plus hautes juridictions françaises et
quatre parlementaires de deux chambres
dont la moitié issue de l'opposition
un contrôle juridictionnel est institué
pour l'intégralité des opérations de
surveillance menées sur le territoire
national et je ne laisserai pas dire que
ce texte de loi pourrait mettre en cause
nos libertés et que nos pratiques
seraient celles que nous condamnons
aujourd'hui ici à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui mesdames et messieurs les
députés nous portons ici dans un esprit
d'unité nationale
l'indignation de la france et les
français et une exigeante de vérité et
l'explication qui doit venir au plus
vite merci monsieur